i've always found that i've learned the
most from the people i surround myself
with
so it's the importance of being
surrounded by not just
like-minded people but unlike-minded
people i always emphasize the importance
of surrounding yourself by as many
unlike-minded people as possible because
they will open up your mind in every
single way possible
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
and is sponsored by leumitech hippo
insurance touring
upwards labs and hillel at stanford
welcome to episode 320 we have with us
jasmine iskenzi
co-founder of the sensory and the
co-founder of health tech hive
jasmine is also co-founder of health
tech hive a global community of change
makers in health tech and conducing
award-winning women's health research
prior to this jasmine worked as a
consultant on projects with the nhsx
on their latest ai initiative and with
longevity international to facilitate
the all-party parliamentary group for
longevity
jasmine s kenzie thank you for being on
my show all the way from london how are
you
i'm absolutely great thank you how are
you michael i
i am doing fantastic so you are in
london right i didn't get that wrong uh
yes yeah
wonderful and how's it going over there
right now uh
chaos absolute chaos but i mean we're
all just trying to keep them
keep our heads up and uh just just keep
going really that's what we're all doing
across the world i think regardless of
where we are
um entrepreneur and you know
the thing that i like that i really
enjoy about this is that this is
actually going to be
published in just a few weeks so we'll
have a you know
in a few weeks we'll see whether the
situation is different but we'll be able
to also reflect on this specific time
when things are going a little bit
chaotic you know here in israel we
have the vaccine rollout and so it's
it's been an interesting time seeing how
the world is is adapting to it
but jasmine we have no time to waste on
covert right now because we have to talk
about
entrepreneurship talk about health tech
talk about the difference
in you know different initiatives that
you've that you've been a part of
gender equality in tech you know
investments and working
now on sensors and helping people be
more in touch with their body
and getting real good insights and then
a few messages to some entrepreneurs
that might be having a little bit of a
tough time so
before we do all that jasmine tell me a
little bit about you who are you
and and what do you do who am i
a great question i think um i'd kick off
by a bit of a bit of my journey really
so i
started off i felt actually accidentally
into health tech
um i did my thesis on artificial
intelligence and creativity and how the
two could kind of
combine you know whether ai could
actually you know ever
take over from the human brain and how
it all interacts i was fascinated by it
and
i then from that fell into looking at
ethics with an ai and then kind of went
into the health tech space
um so started as a consultant and worked
on some really fascinating projects
um with nhsx on how to implement
artificial intelligence into the
healthcare system in the uk
um and work with the all party
parliamentary group for longevity
um on how we can help people live longer
lives which again is
something we're still grappling with um
but yeah and from there
noticed a massive need um for
inclusivity and collaboration within the
health tech space
because often what's happening in health
tech is we're working in silos
so you know you have you'll have the
techies all together and you'll have
the marketing team who have the
clinicians together and i think what's
really wonderful
and the way we actually get change
happening is by working collaboratively
so from that um a great friend of mine
and i started running these events
just initially with friends that were a
mix of visionaries
founders clinicians doctors data
scientists and we started running just
these like supper clubs
and from there it started growing and
growing we have people saying we want to
join it was all predominantly women
and then we started you know we had uh
events with google
and from babylon out with nhs and it
just grew and we
since then we've grown a global
community and that's health tech hive
we've also been working on women's
health research initiatives which
um have been really great fun looking at
the areas of unmet need in women's
health which have been fascinating
um and then from for the past year i've
actually worked on a project called the
sensory
so the sensory is actually looking at
how we can combine neuroscience
and sensory experiences to help people
get into mood states
so right we're looking we're looking at
how you can
turn down your tech tune into your
senses
and then tap into mood states so
well also ultimately what we're looking
at is kind of how you can use things
like binaural beats
to get you into different states of
productivity or creativity wait wait
wait wait wait
that was gibberish to me i need a little
bit of dumb it down for me what
was that word that he just said binaural
beats
okay what does that mean and and and
after that
i want to know a little bit more about
your take on the world and why do we
even need
you know whatever sensor he's doing
right now
so binaural beats the way that it works
is you have two different frequencies in
your ear that actually
in either ear but then create a
frequency within your head
and it's been scientifically proven that
that can actually help you get into
states of
focus creativity really
yeah it's fascinating i think after this
um you should definitely
check out some binaural beats playlist
or i'll send you some of the ones that
we've been working on because i know
what i'm doing for the rest of the day
yeah
the effects have been amazing from the
ones that we've been building and
designing ourselves
you know just watching how they've
helped us get into the flow of
of work because i think the biggest
issue a lot of us are struggling with at
the moment is
staying focused you know we're living in
this like distraction
distraction world where everything's
trying to take our attention
um and i think you know you've got
notifications going off and i always say
notifications are the killers of
creativity they just
you know every time you're brainstorming
suddenly something an email will come up
or someone will take your
your attention away we can't really stay
in that flow very much anymore
um so it's a case of how we can keep
people in that flow get them into that
before
they're engaging with meetings or
projects so so that's kind of what we're
working on
and how do you even get to how do you
get to think about
these binaural beats and then
frequencies and and helping people get
into the right
the right you know um right flows how do
you even get there
a lot of a lot of rece reading of
academic research and well i'm a
musician myself i've written music since
i was 11 years old and loved the idea
that
sound and music it can completely take
us away from wherever we are
and it can just take us into another
space and then
this this whole idea started actually in
san francisco um and we were at a sound
sculpturing
uh workshop where you had no sensory
stimulus it was just your sense of sound
um and you kind of listened to these
amazing sounds and you suddenly got into
such an incredible space
and we thought what if you could isolate
each of the senses
and use those to help you get into
potentially creativity
positivity relaxation or
you know um any of those any of those
mood states so that's kind of where we
where we got to and we realized that
color has a massive impact on your on
your mind for example you know
you look at a purple for example after
15 minutes it starts to become a very
creative color
from being relaxed relaxing to being
creative so
and then sense of smell you know citrus
is very uplifting you know lavender's
relaxing all these different things we
can actually be doing throughout our day
to help us
you know get into different states
throughout the day so it's i think a lot
a lot to be said and done for
using the senses to help you get into
different states and how do you actually
so
what is the actual you know customer
journey that that that interacts with
with the sensory is it you know
primarily researchers are there products
with it how does it actually work
so at the moment where we're creating
our mvp so we've got an mvp app
that we're developing that we'll be
kicking off next month
and so at the moment we're looking at
kind of using breath work
sound these binaural beats and different
colors
uh affirmations and then we're kind of
combining that with sense of smells and
different foods that you can be you know
having that can get you into different
mood states so it's an app at the moment
and then what we'd love to do it was
meant to be actually a building
and every room in this sensory building
was going to kind of
uh you know be based on a different
sense unfortunately due to covid we had
to
to put that on pause but that's
definitely in the pipeline for having
you know
multi-sensory buildings and work spaces
that could help you get into it and
activate these states of mind
no i think that's just amazing and talk
to me a little bit about the health tech
health tech hive what was that about and
how does
how do you you know you you work through
that to really get to know
the health takes space that's a great
question
i think so so you know for me
i've always found that i've learned the
most from the people i surround myself
with
so it's the importance of being
surrounded by not just
like-minded people but unlike-minded
people i always emphasize the importance
of surrounding yourself by as many
unlike-minded people as possible because
they will open up your mind in every
single way possible
so with health tech hive i think the big
the big key for us was
how can we get as many unlike-minded
people together to tackle issues such as
you know
um ethics with an ai or how do we how
can we look at investment and how can we
look at investment and actually
helping female founders for example get
more investment but let's not just
tackle this from an investment
investor perspective let's ask the
entrepreneurs what they want let's ask
like
clinicians let's ask the data scientist
let's ask absolutely everyone and
from all different areas of um health
tech
so you know for mental health or you
know whatever it could be women's health
at any area
we want to kind of pull all of those
expertise and perspectives and i think
that was a massive draw for thinking
right this needs to happen and
that that same ethos i think should be
applied to all industries
you know i think actually getting
unlike-minded people around key topics
and just
having all of their visions and and
listening to each other
especially now we're looking at the
world's becoming more and more polarized
unfortunately
right so i think you know actually
seeing hearing all these different
perspectives is
fundamental at the moment i i i
completely agree and i think that
you know what i've been learning through
interacting with people with different
with different mindsets and you know
part of the motivation for this show is
for me to get exposed and to get
inspired by
you know a lot of the episodes i don't
even agree with with what
with what i'm hearing or i didn't i
don't think of it in the same regard but
just hearing that
opposite side or or that you know
parallel side and thinking okay well
what can i learn from this person what
can i take away from this
insight and then bring it to me i think
that that's really the growth and that's
where
it happens it's very easy to be in your
own silo and to go
and to just surround yourself with
people with people that are that are
exactly the same to and i think that
part of the problem that has been
outlined in the past few years you know
really ever since 2016
with the us election you've you're
seeing that these social social media
networks are
really putting you in the same right
sort of silo with like-minded people
and i think that both what you did in
the health tech hive and what i am
trying to do here is sort of expand
beyond that and say okay well there's a
world of you know experts and thinkers
that are just that i would love to to
get to know and i think that's exactly
the right the right way so i really
appreciate that jasmine talk a little
bit about your entrepreneurial
experience you mentioned right before we
started here that
you know you you've had a lot of
challenges yourself over this past year
and there you really you know there's a
lot a lot of things that you've been
thinking about that
you think might be also relevant for
some other young entrepreneurs
i i think being an entrepreneur is
hard at the best of times being an
entrepreneur in the middle of a pandemic
is a whole another ball game i'm sure
you know this and i'm sure that any
other
entrepreneurs or do you know what anyone
listening to this is going through
a really massive you know
inner and outer turmoil of where they're
at what they're doing
and i think some of the key things i've
learned this year is
instead of being so kind of fixated on
timelines
and very clear goals and objectives and
being done by certain it's finished by
certain points
i actually think as an entrepreneur
enjoying the journey is fundamental
right so for me i've kind of thought
right i wanted to have this down by
you know the next six months the next
year and enjoying and relishing that
journey
because of kovid and the crazy world
situation
none of us really are probably exactly
where we want to be
you know and there are so many projects
that i was so excited for and funding
unfortunately due to covid was
put on pause so i then again have very
flexible and you know the the concept
that we have for the zentree was meant
to be a building and we had to pivot and
then it was a kind of a completely other
idea and now it's developed into an app
and it's
constantly this ability to be flexible
and almost to go with the flow you know
to
to accept that not everything is going
to be able to be
held up against metrics and very clear
deadlines i think
this year anyone should just be able to
think okay
it's actually okay that i'm not exactly
there right now and being kind to
yourself is fundamental
no i think that i think that the stick
on on grid resilience but
and then the core of core of
entrepreneurship and core of of going
through that is also getting the
excitement through the
through the tourmaline through the
difficulties right and i think that that
it's a pretty good test to know whether
you know when you have these
difficulties are you excited about them
are you excited to come down the other
side
innovate through the different
challenges and you know i've seen
a breadth of of entrepreneurs and i
can't wait to go on my own journey
pretty soon but i've seen through this
past year a birth of entrepreneurs that
tackled whatever
new challenges that came up because
every single entrepreneur had
very drastically different challenges
than what they anticipated probably as a
result of covet
and seeing how people navigate through
that but and more than the strategies
they employed to tackle them
their mindset and how they communicate
with people
and you know a lot of them saying like
you know there are those that over
communicated and those that under
communicated
and i love that split because i think
pretty linearly you can see those that
over communicated even if their strategy
wasn't spot on
they got through it because they wanted
to get through it and everybody
was in it together and i think that what
you're saying here is is completely
right what is the thing that most
excites you about your journey right now
there is honestly so much that excites
me that's probably half of the problem
i think so much of what i'm doing
excites me and that's another learning i
think when you do get so excited and
about what you're doing you know on this
journey i think you've got to actually
be quite disciplined as to where you
focus your energy
right that's that's also another really
important thing that i've actually had
to learn because
you know you can get excited and wanting
to get involved at every step of the way
and actually you have to be like right i
focus my energy
here and this is what needs to be done
first and you know that kind of time
management and organization
you know we hear it all the time but
actually putting it into practice is so
important
so right what most excites me i think
it's the
the actual ability to to kind of provide
something that will
i genuinely feel will help people in
their day
i see everyone around me constantly
unable really to kind of fully engage in
the moment and to ever really get things
done to the way they want to if we can
provide us this
tool to help people actually efficiently
you know throughout their day get their
work done or to be more creative
or you know to actually harness that
that potential
within that within their brain to almost
like hack into their own brain
and to be able to think right today this
is what i want to get done let's get it
done in a small amount of time so then
maybe they can get
more time with their family or with
their friends or they can do more sport
because what's happening especially with
clothed and people working from home is
a blurring of
the work and the play you know everyone
suddenly
it's emails are going off from 8 a.m and
they're going on until 11 p.m and
there's no
clear boundary anymore you know we need
to be looking after ourself
and our own well-being and our own
health i think if this he has taught us
anything of the importance of health
so you know if we can actually provide a
tool that helps people
throughout their day to kind of really
compartmentalize to be the best version
of themselves that
really excites me no i think that's
that's spot on and i think that one
thing that
you're really what you're talking here
is about being intentional with what you
want to achieve right
and i think that's that's that's really
really spot on uh
because one of the things that i that
this blurriness is disturbing is this
intentionality that you know you're
sitting down and everything's you know
you're not really sure like
what's the priority now and everything
is like sort of one big mixture of
things
and and so i think that what you're
doing with sensory and i'm gonna have to
check out
the this whole frequency thing and
mineral bits that you're talking about
because i'm i'm really into
a you know deep technology and
neuroscience and i think that's that's
exactly where we're headed
and you know also looking from a
behavioral economics perspective
you can you know it's it's not just
about you know being intentional and
then just using your own willpower to go
and focus you know it's really hard to
take
you know somebody is a person okay now
you focus
but by helping them change amend their
environment
to help them focus that i think is is
one of the biggest keys jasmine
before you founded zenser you also
co-founded a bunch of other initiatives
but you're also
managing partnerships for various
organizations
how early on do you consider yourself an
entrepreneur
that's a really good really good
question
i think there's a difference between
being an entrepreneur and having an
entrepreneurial mindset
i think since a young age i remember
being at school and
constantly wanting to reinvent things
seeing the way that things are done and
wanting to reinvent
things in my lessons i remember you know
thinking that a lot of school was too
linear it was too restrictive
and i remember sitting in an art class
and i created this
this very out there wacky piece of art
it was like perspex and it had
you know um real petals in it and i
painted a woman out of chili's into lots
of different teacups and she aged in
every single
teacup and i remember my teacher turning
around to me and saying
jasmine this is great but it's not on
the syllabus so i can't give you a good
mark
and already then i thought that's a
that's creativity
that's thinking out of the box but this
school system is not facilitating that
so i think that mindset of of kind of
thinking
well that should change and wanting to
do things differently was already an
entrepreneurial mindset so i think since
a young age i kind of
wanted to to find ways around things or
be more creative or do things that
weren't necessarily on a syllabus
and that mindset i think we should be
encouraging young people to be doing
it's that that notion of you don't have
to always you know
just follow everything else you can do
things differently you can
see things that are wrong and you can
reinvent them yourself so i think it's
from a young age and i think
we should actually be encouraging young
people and teaching them those skills
within school i i completely agree and i
think that there there is you know
there's a big trend that's saying
you know you'll allow kids to to
innovate to experiment to do to do
but not just give them that a mark based
on the exact rubric but i think there's
there has to be an interesting balance
there because you know i remember myself
an entrepreneur at heart from a very
young age defying a lot of standards and
and sort of breaking the rules and i was
very lucky to have
a community that supported me throughout
breaking those rules
but i do think that you know at the end
most people aren't necessarily
entrepreneurial and spirit
a lot of people like stability they like
you know knowing
what is the process and and following
that process and becoming experts in
that process
and so i think that there has to be a
good balance that both allows
people to to go that right and allows
people to go that route and so i i think
that what you're saying here is
is is really really spot on where do you
see
sensory if you look you know five years
in the future
and interplay with how we consume
health technology and then have it be
part of our daily life
that's that's a really good question i
think
the way i would absolutely love to see
it is to kind of have it as a a tool
you could work with so that as you said
previously you could actually facilitate
an environment
from the moment that you wake up that
you can you can straight away feel in a
positive mindset you're ready to tackle
the day
you go into your office and that again
facilitates you to sit down to focus to
be in the zone
and then when you need to be creative
and brainstorm you are able to do that
not only because your physical space
is like that but you've actually learned
the tools as well you know it's not just
your physical space as you said earlier
it's very much as well internal it's
that discipline it's that
understanding of the self and how the
brain works i think it's hugely
important
for all of us to understand as well to
an extent so that we can again
you know be most efficient in what we're
doing i think
yeah it would be a tool that people
could actually have throughout their day
to use to actually help them get into
those mood states and also to have
buildings that people can go to
and they can let themselves they can it
can be a mind spa
we've got we've got spas for the body
we've got gyms for the body
we need more spaces for the mind for the
mental health yes
we need spaces and cities that are full
of nature
where people can switch off they can
have no tech they can engage
they can be present if we can actually
have cities that facilitate these spaces
and
and actually facilitate growth and
creativity and mind wandering and
switching off that would be honestly an
incredible incredible place in five
years time that's what i would envisage
having those kind of spaces in other
cities
jasmine i love it i love your energy i
love your perspective on both
entrepreneurship but also where we're
headed in terms of
of health tech and and i think that
sensory really is you know
it's a combination of all those things
so so thank you very much for for being
so generous with your time and for
coming here and sharing it with me
and before we leave after asking the
most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
oh i think three words i'd used to
describe myself as
passionate energetic and
having a zest for life i love it
i love it jasmine thank you so so much
stay safe and stay healthy and i can't
wait to see where sensory goes
thank you thank you so much
[Music]
you